a series of extraordinary late night
moments to end an extraordinary week
this is the man who would be speaker
heading to confront the man who just
blocked him
Kevin McCarthy had thought this 14th
vote would be his
he thought he could count on the
Maverick controversial conservative Matt
Gates on the left gray suit we can't
hear what they're saying but it is angry
stuff
it's after 11 pm they've been voting for
four days unprecedented for over a
century a government paralyzed then look
at this from behind another Congressman
approaches orange Thai Mike Rogers with
a few words of his own for Mr Gates then
restrained by another
this is today's Republican party and on
January the 6th it turns out the
anniversary of an Insurrection which was
fostered by some of these people
it went on a few yards away another
congresswoman conspiracy theorist
Marjorie Taylor green controversial even
within her own party she has a call it's
Donald Trump DT to her he is still
pulling the strings or doing his very
best to
bobert
his divisive politics enabled this
Fringe group of ultra conservatives now
disrupting on their own
it's been four days of Kevin McCarthy
capitulating to their Fringe demands
they get to call the shots because the
Republican majority is so tiny
it looked like it was all over for
McCarthy for the week at least but then
the man who had voted no moments earlier
had suddenly changed his mind
for what purpose does the gentleman from
Minnesota rise Madam clerk I Rise to say
wow
deals done Democratic compromise or
desperate infighting which will put
McCarthy as speaker in a straight jacket
unable to govern to lead this place
and so there was another vote and this
time he got it
of which the
ancorthy of the
Kevin McCarthy the 55th speaker of the
United States House of Representatives
[Applause]
that was easy huh
I never thought we'd get up here
he'd reached the third highest office in
the land but through the most
extraordinary and messy of weeks Mark
Stone Sky News in Washington